what up space fam golden here from anime
uproar back at it again to discuss the
latest and craziest developments in the
boruto story
this chapter is a game changer as we
learn so much about the new borto
villains and about boruto's tragic
decline
so make sure to stay tuned for that if
you do enjoy these naruto and borto
videos and want to keep them coming
please smash that like button and
comment it's an absolutely free way to
support this channel
if you're new or maybe if you watched
some of our videos but haven't
subscribed yet make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications
before we get into it a quick thank you
to world of tanks for sponsoring this
video
world of tanks is a free to play mmo
with over
100 million players worldwide this epic
pc
tank battle simulator has over 550 tanks
to choose from
and more than 40 different maps that you
can transform into a massive battlefield
and now world of tanks is having a
collaboration with none other than girls
un panzer as soon as i heard of this
collab
i thought it was both hilarious and
absolutely perfect
and i can't wait to experience the
multiple girls unpanzer theme the battle
missions
that are coming to the game these
missions will offer a ton of awesome
rewards
and the game is adding a new tier 5
premium
tank the pz4 aust h
onco from girls un panzer the
collaboration will also feature
the original voice actors from the anime
for the different scenarios of crew
management
download world of tanks right now by
clicking the first link down in the
description
during the registration use the code
girlsoonpanzer2021
to get for free 3x decal with miho
nishizumi 6x angler fish emblem
6x panzer vor inscription
500 gold three days premium 100 000
credits
and the polish tank tks
z and km don't miss this awesome girls
unpanzer collaboration which will happen
from april 27th
to may 6th but the invite code rewards
will still be available after those
dates
download world of tanks now link in the
description and now without further ado
let's jump into its spoilers and all the
cover page for this one
is none other than ada the girl code
referred to
as the one who knows everything in this
world in the last chapter
last chapter we learned about code that
his abilities exceeded even jigen's
and so in code's case he had limiters
put in
to check his formidable strength so he
wouldn't undermine jegan's position as a
leader
it's always pretty hype when someone's
power needs to be limited rather than
increased in fact amato said last
chapter that there were several cyborgs
that greatly surpassed jegan's power but
they were disposed of
and ada is clearly one of those op
cyborgs that isn't even supposed to be
alive anymore
back to this chapter and code wants to
wake up ada but before that
bug tells code that his thinking is too
naive
clearly even compared to code ada's
powers are something special
bug says that you can't make her obey
with brute force
and that out of all of them meaning
those op cyborgs
aydah is a completely different class
they are definitely building her new
powers up here and it's totally possible
that when they finally meet up with
boruto and kawaki
one will fight code and the other will
fight ada
this is more interesting than just code
although i'm sure he'll be a beast too
when he gets his limiters off code goes
on to break ada out even before
bug is done explaining about her code is
not worried
saying he'll kill her if she disobeys
but there's a big catch which we'll
figure out later
for now naruto tells the other kage
about code and his plans to avenge
ishiki
and to cultivate a divine tree from ten
tales i really like seeing all the kage
like this and you can see that they're
worried about fighting the ten tails
again
i hope these guys will play a larger
role in this and upcoming arcs but for
now it's just an extremely epic ninja
skype call
people question a motto and whether he's
trustworthy and
are to admit he doesn't trust him 100
but the cool scientists did help them
against ishiki and save the village in
the process
so he considers that proof enough
combine this with the fact that he's
being targeted and that his intel
so far has been credible and amado
pretty much gets a pass for now from the
kage
gara though is more concerned about
momoshiki taking over boruto
naruto is honest saying they're
searching for a solution and it doesn't
look good but at least for now borto is
doing fine
gara straight up asks if momoshiki or
boruto himself
were to become an ishiki level threat
would naruto be able to take down his
own son and without flinching naruto
says that he'll do what he needs to do
as hokage this is a big moment for
naruto
of course he loves his kid and this is
extremely hard for him to say but it
also shows how much he's grown
as a kid he didn't even want to consider
an alternative to
saving sasuke and here he's implying
that if need be
he'll put down boruto that would truly
be a heartbreaking and tragic situation
if it ever came to that
but also without kurama it definitely
won't be easy to beat a full power
momoshiki
we'll see what happens but the stakes
are definitely high right now
and this is quite the terrible situation
for naruto to be in
we jump to amado and naruto talking
about the situation
naruto pretty much says he doesn't want
to believe that boruto could become a
completely different alien person
and he'd rather not think about it until
the moment it happens
and amado can seemingly relate to how he
feels our cool scientist says that he
used to have a daughter
and so he knows how naruto feels it's
been 12 years since she died according
to him
but i wonder if ada is a creation in
some way related to his daughter
this detail would seem pretty random
otherwise let me know what you think
about it in the comments
finally amado gives naruto some pills
saying that it's not that naruto doesn't
want to believe that boruto will become
a villain he just doesn't want to give
up on his son the aim of the pills is to
weaken the byakugan amado originally
made it to take down jigen since the
byakugan comes from the otsutsuki
weakening it might curtail the otsutuki
vacation
of boruto's cells but and this is a big
but
amado says he wouldn't normally
recommend it because it could cause
anything from decreased vision to even
death and despite the horrible risks
the best they're hoping to do is curtail
the momoshiki takeover temporarily
they don't solve the problem at its core
a model leaves it to naruto and boruto
to decide what to do
and he tells naruto to make sure that
hinata or his daughter don't take it
implying it would definitely be bad for
them naruto takes the pills but honestly
it doesn't seem like a good idea from my
perspective
even if it doesn't kill boruto it could
weaken him and they need him strong for
this upcoming fight
but i guess naruto also has to consider
that like last time momoshiki can take
over and cause havoc to the village and
as hokage
he might have to try anything he can to
prevent that we jump back to code and
ada code threatens to kill the former
sleeping beauty
and she tells him to try but he can't
bring himself to do it turns out this is
another one of her op
powers she can steal hearts hilariously
enough
she's worried about having bad breath
after sleeping for so long
a concern you don't come across a lot in
anime so she goes to brush her teeth
in the meantime bug explains that she
stole code's heart
and that's why he couldn't kill her
pretty much it's as if he loves her now
bug even says code's done for although
he wanted to be the one in charge if ada
wishes it
he'll pretty much have to take a
backseat to her i like when code remarks
that clairvoyance is cheating enough
but having this ability on top of that
is just amazing
i look forward to seeing how impressive
her combat skills might be as well
i gotta say i do already prefer her to
sakura after brushing her teeth aydah
comes in saying that her clairvoyance
ability
is not that great it's like having
access to security cameras in every nook
all over the world you know jaraya would
have loved that power for research
reasons ada actually says she's bored of
that power
although she does occasionally see some
interesting stuff
like how ishiki died she straight up
says that it was pathetic the way ishiki
died to his most
loyal follower she feels bad that he
tasked code with so many things
we find out that she can pretty much see
anything that happened
anywhere past included all the way up to
the point where she was born and she
can't see beyond that
it's an extremely useful ability but not
broken enough to let you see the future
or anything like that
still she'd be invaluable for giving
information about konoha and its ninja
imagine standing a chance against
someone who can spy on all of your
planning
and knows where you are all the time and
what you're doing
all in all it's a very interesting power
and a game changer
it'll be much easier to get to a motto
with this ability so that he can release
code's limiters
according to code he already feels like
he can kill sasuke naruto
but he wants to spare himself any
unnecessary hardship
and this sounds super cocky but we gotta
remember that naruto and sasuke have
been heavily nerfed and i do
think he'll manage to get his limiters
removed so that will definitely be a
pretty difficult fight for our guys our
cool scientist amado
has set things up well to the point
where a transformation jutsu of him
won't do
since he set it up to need iris
recognition a voice print command
code and he's also remodeled his eyes
with science
so that no transformation jutsu could
replicate them pretty interesting stuff
in props to our boy amato but what does
confuse me is that ada
says she doesn't know what the code word
is even though i would assume
she could look back in time and figure
it out let me know if i'm missing
something in the comments and that may
very well be explained later
but anyways we carry on now knowing that
a model pretty much made it so that they
need his cooperation
in order to unlock the limiters amado's
done a great job of ensuring his safety
throughout this whole story
i gotta say interestingly enough aydah
doesn't like amado as much as i do
aydah says she hates a motto and plans
to kill him the next time she sees him
her reason is not that he just remodeled
her body
but that he made it so that everyone
becomes captivated by her both men and
women
and although that sounds nice at first
glance i actually understand why it
bothers her she's crushed by the fact
that she'll never know if people truly
would have liked her
if not for her ability and not to
mention it gets boring as she mentions
it reminds me of that great twilight
zone episode
called a nice place to visit a robber
ends up in a place that seems like
heaven
every woman there wants to be with him
and he wins
every time he gambles but after only a
month he becomes
so bored of having his whims instantly
satisfied
he tells pip who he presumes as his
angel that he doesn't like heaven and he
wants to go to the other place
pip responds and i quote heaven whatever
gave you the idea you were in heaven
this is the other place end quote it's
one of my
favorite episodes of the twilight zone
and it can really help us
understand why ada who seems like a
spoiled brat at first glance
feels the way she does after a motto
robbed her of ordinary love as she said
we do get a pretty hilarious moment
where code asks how come bug isn't
affected by her ability after seeing his
behavior but aydah explains that people
show love differently bug doesn't show
it externally and he's also a chicken
man you gotta feel bad for bug at this
point but nevertheless i like that it
emphasizes
how not everyone will act on their
feelings the same way
finally we get the answer to what some
of us were probably thinking how could
jigen
order her disposal if he loved her too
and the answer is that he didn't
her ability has no effect against blood
relatives or the otutsuki so the pattern
of the otsutsuki being opie and immune
to just about everything
is going to continue again that blood
relative comment
seems pretty noteworthy further
suggesting her connection to amado's
dead daughter
it's pointed out to us that because
boruto and kawaki have karmas
and went through quite a bit of
otsutsuki vacation they both won't be
affected by her abilities
she has especially taken a liking to
kawaki who fooled ishiki
her heart fluttered as she watched him
an extremely rare occurrence for her
there's a saying that people want what
they can't have
and i bet this girl will be all the more
into kawaki if he rejects her and how
she'll react to that
will be very interesting to see it's
pretty hilarious how she doesn't care
about boruto even though he's one of
like only two
options for her even though she doesn't
even know how kawaki will respond
she's already decided what she wants
which makes sense because she's used to
getting whatever she wants
for borto she's totally cool with using
him as ten tails fodder
to cultivate a divine tree pretty
randomly and hilariously ada lets us
know that she's monogamous
so she won't miss boruto i love how
she's already so sure that the romance
with kawaki will work out you gotta
respect that confidence
ada lets us know that she's spying on
the kange meeting right now and thanks
to her
no matter what plan they come up with
code will never be caught
like i said she's ultra useful the two
share drinks and toast to their goals
for revenge and a boyfriend respectively
and that is it for this chapter i gotta
admit i'm intrigued to see how this goes
on a side note i'm still also looking
for kashin koji
to come out of the woodworks it seemed
like with the sasuke and naruto nerfs
boruto and kawaki were being set up as
the key to beating code
and that's even more so the case now
with aida's abilities
it should be interesting to see naruto
and sasuke falling for her i think that
has potential to be pretty hilarious
i look forward to seeing how that goes
but that is it for this one thank you so
much for watching
as always let me know in the comments
how you enjoyed this chapter
and what you're excited to see next if
you do enjoy these naruto and boruto
videos and want to keep them going
please smash that like button and
comment
it's an absolutely free way to support
the channel if you're new or if you
watch some of our videos but haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications turning on all
notifications is the only way to make
sure that youtube
will actually show you our video
otherwise you could easily miss a whole
bunch of them while you're waiting for
the next video to drop
feel free to check out our growing
naruto slash boruto playlist which
includes highly requested videos about
the otsutsuki
uzumaki hokage and much more link to
that is in the description
and you can leave any other suggestions
for future videos in the comments as
well
and thanks once again to world of tanks
for sponsoring this video don't miss
this awesome girls unponzel
collaboration
download world of tanks now link in the
description
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you